okay we're well and truly on the
downhill now here is part h it says from
parts f and g it follows that and then
you've got this inequality result here
now really carefully because i know the
first time i had a look at this i
thought okay so i've got to proof this
result and then i read it again and i
said oh no they're just telling you this
they're giving you a corollary a sort of
consequence that you can draw out of
parts f and g which we just proved
they're just handing this to you okay
and if you want you can go back to f and
g and see how this inequality arrives
what they want you to do is use this
result take it as given
and then add it with this substitution x
equals
pi on 2 sine t so let's just highlight
that there
they want us to use that and then this
is the thing we actually have to
establish this is the result i'm
required to prove bn is less than or
equal to this which is less than or
equal to this so it's a lot going on
here right there's this sort of
multi-part inequality which is in a
sense just two inequality questions
rammed into one and you just want to do
them independently and then you link
them right using that common piece in
the middle
you can see if you look carefully that
there's a relationship between this
result that they've told you comes from
f and g and then this result which
you're required to prove right have a
look you've got b n over here on the
left hand side and then you've got this
series of very similar looking things
right you've got
the same old integral from naught to pi
on two there it is the coefficient the
constant coefficient that's been removed
out is very suspiciously similar not
identical but you've got what color have
i got left
i'll use this red you've got pi squared
up here so there's like a pi cubed so
it's a pi squared and somehow another pi
arrives you've got that same n plus 1
hanging out there on the denominator and
then you can see
the 8 is somehow going to turn into a
16. so in fact what we're off by is a
factor of pi on 2 right can you see that
if i multiply this by pi on 2 you get to
this and that should make you very
suspicious of the pi on 2 that appears
in this substitution they've asked us to
work with
so here's going to be my roadmap what
i'm going to do is i'm going to start
with
this result over here i'm going to try
and manipulate it using this
substitution and i hope it will land me
here slightly weird that there are signs
and i should end up on cosines but it
wouldn't be the first time even in this
question that we've just kind of treated
them as somewhat interchangeable and
made an exchange between them using the
appropriate identity all right so that's
the roadmap let's have a go i'm going to
start by writing the substitution
they've handed us right which is x
equals pi on 2
sine
t alright
from here
i'm going to do all the normal things
that i i need to in order to make a
substitution you can see up here i'm
going to have to change some boundaries
i'm going to have to um you know change
my variable of integration and there's
also this x squared term here i want to
i want to deal with that and make sure
i've got all the right pieces in terms
of t okay so let's have a go what did i
say before we're going to have to do
boundaries change the variable
integration let's start with boundaries
okay
so over here let's just draw a line over
here
[Applause]
okay boundaries here we come so
previously i had x equals 0 and x equals
pi on 2. so when i substitute that in
what's t going to give me well
i'm going to have
think about this right
not t equals i'm going to have 0 equals
pi on 2 sine t well divide through by pi
on 2 it doesn't matter
what value of t is going to be
appropriate to give me 0 on the left
hand side and the answer is well t
equals 0 we'll do it right now of course
t equals 0 is not the only value that is
necessary but if you have a think about
what you're dealing with here it's an
appropriate place to start and it's
going to be an appropriate place to end
so i'm going to set that as the most
appropriate solution to give me a
reasonable value so that's going to be t
equals 0.
kind of cute funny thing happens when
you substitute in x equals pi on 2
because then what you've got is
pi on 2
equals pi on 2
sine
t so you're like oh okay i guess i'll
just divide through that gives me sine t
equals 1. so again choosing the most
appropriate value the first one that's
going to give us a satisfactory solution
is
pi on 2. so finally enough our x equals
0 becomes t equals 0 and our x equals
planet 2 becomes d equals pi and 2. so
weird all right
let's keep on going let's have a look at
changing the variable of integration so
i need to work out what looking at this
i need to work out what dx on dt is here
pi on 2 is just the constant coefficient
sine is just going to turn into cos so
let's just jot that down dx on dt
it's going to be pi on 2
cos t all right fantastic and then you
actually have to look at the integrand
itself so when you have a look see here
we've dealt with the boundaries we dealt
with the variable of integration what is
this thing going to be equal to now i
could substitute in x equals 2 sine t
alongside doing the integration at the
same time but
i'm just trying to reduce my cognitive
load and have as few things going on in
my brain simultaneously as i can so i'm
just going to work out what 4x squared
on pi squared is in terms of this and
then i'm going to substitute all in one
here okay so
when i go down over this direction
let's say
if x is pi on 2 sine t then x squared is
going to be
pi squared on 4
sine
squared t i think i squared everything
okay and then what i'm going to do is i
want 4 on pi squared which looks a bit
suspicious doesn't it i'm multiplying
through by the reciprocal of this
coefficient so therefore when i multiply
through by 4
on pi
squared on the right hand side you just
end up with sine squared t
that looks like it's going to be useful
okay so i'm ready to go let's go ahead
and change um our let's just do our
substitution okay
so originally we had our integral from
naught pi on 2 because i'm doing a
change of variable and because it just
so happens that my boundaries are
actually the same i'm going to be very
explicit you guys have seen in sigma
notation you know they state for you
what the the
pronumeral the sort of the dummy
variable is down the bottom and in sort
of you know calculus integral notation
we tend to drop that off but just
because i'm changing this i think it's a
good thing to actually say
so that's there and then what i've got
is what do we have
1 minus 4x squared on pi squared it's
all raised to the power of n plus 1
that's with respect to x okay here we go
time to make our substitutions
i'm going to go from t equals 0 to t
equals pi on 2 so that looks good
inside the brackets here you can see i'm
going to get 1 minus and i went and
found that that is just going to be sine
squared that's handy so
1 minus sine squared t and then when i'm
doing my
substitution here at the end here to
change my variable of integration you
can see that dx i can replace with a pi
on 2 cos t
dt so
i will pop that in green since that's
what i was doing over there so this is
pi on two
cos t
d t and i'll just for completeness sake
i'll highlight this in blue because you
can see where i got that from
okay happy times so now on the right
hand side you can see oh this is going
to have that pi on 2 is going to come
out the front like i wanted
that's going to multiply through like i
identified just here so you can change
that coefficient that's out the front
okay so that's promising
i'm going to say lazy this is from nor
to pound two i'll drop off the t next i
think it's obvious what i've done
and oh that was a bit sneaky of me
wasn't it i forgot to raise this to the
appropriate power which is n plus one
this is cos squared t to the power of n
plus one right so cos
squared
to the power of n plus one but then
you've got check this out another cause
right so you can see now why the power
in this
middle term here is like oh two n plus
three where did that come from answer
this is going to give you 2n plus 2 and
this is going to be the increment up to
plus 3 okay and then that's all with
respect to 2.
okay fantastic now we can say this is
equal to pi on 2
multiply on 2 let's just do that
expansion there because of 2 n plus 3 of
t
dt okay excellent now this is so
important um because it's kind of this
result that i'm going to need to put
into here i'm going to name it okay so
i'm going to call this
equation 1 right and you can see where
it's come from so as soon as i get this
oopsie daisy let's try that again mist
the top of the pie don't do that
so let's grab that
as soon as i see this result here whoops
so uncoordinated just because i've been
doing so much writing there we go as
soon as i receive something to do with
this i can substitute it for this and
that's going to give me the result that
i need with this sort of linked
inequality okay so i can say
um given that you know in the question
do you remember f and g tell me this
remember that and then what you've got
here on the right hand side is the thing
i'm going to substitute for this cos 2 n
plus three business okay so what i'm
going to say is since
uh b n is less than or equal to there's
the pi squared on eight n plus one then
the integral from naught to pi onto in
fact i think i have everything
up here
like so right where did that come from
answer it was given to me in this
particular question so i'll just say
given
i'm now going to do this substitution
right so i hope you can see that i'm
going to substitute let's highlight it
uh this is green i'm going to highlight
this here
let's fill that in
i'm going to substitute that for being
it's the same as this result over here
i'm going to substitute it for this cos
to the 2n plus 3 t
dt okay and that's going to go in place
here and the inequality will be
preserved because these two things are
equal after all okay so what that's
going to give me is
b n is less than or equal to pi squared
on
8 n plus 1. and then comes everything
that i did here right you see that
that's me doing that substitution so i'm
going to say that it's all multiplied
and i'm getting that
by substituting one
so that's where i got that result from
okay and from here you're like oh great
the sort of pi cube is going to appear
the 16 is going to appear so i've got uh
you know sort of two of the bits of the
three part inequality that i want right
so i've got b and is less than or equal
to right pi cubed on 16 and plus one
and then everything in this integral is
looking good okay
so fantastic this is happy um i'm going
to refer back to this um shortly so you
can say okay i've got this result here
i'm just going to call this 2 and i'm
going to substitute it back in a second
now we have this linked inequality right
i said it's really two inequality
questions balled into one right so being
that i've dealt with let's have a look
here i'm actually might delete all this
other working here now because we've
done this part so i can say that we are
now going to focus on this side here
right so you're like
what's happening well in the first
instance what i can say is look the pi
cubed on 16 n plus one is the same here
and here so i'm actually just going to
momentarily disregard it okay then
you've just got this integral in here
and a n comes back right i haven't dealt
with that for a while what is a n again
well if you have a think about if it's
still kicking around in your memory it's
the integral from naught to pi on 2 of
cos to the 2n
t
dt okay or rather it's actually all in
terms of x's but it's a dummy variable
right so t dt x dx theta d theta it's
all the same okay now what i want to do
is compare
you can see we've already noticed that
the constant coefficients identical the
boundaries are identical really all the
action is happening in here
right this is what's different
to this right
we're saying that apparently this result
will always be less than or equal to
this result
how does that work well remember that
integrals can be interpreted as areas
under a curve so if we're thinking about
this as areas under a curve why would it
be like what's the actual difference
between this term and this term which is
apparently less than or equal to and the
answer is to get from here to here
you're multiplying by cos t and you're
doing it three times that's what gives
you this plus three here right the thing
is in this particular domain from naught
to pi on two cos t is always between
naught and one right so when you
multiply you know if you have some some
number n right you multiply it by some
other number which i'm telling you is
between naught and one the biggest it
can be is the original size if you
multiply by one you just get back n but
any of the other options you're going to
get something smaller right and if you
did this this repeated this process
three times to do the plus three you'll
get smaller and smaller and smaller or
at the best case scenario you stay equal
to the same size and that's exactly what
this inequality sign means right you'll
be smaller or you'll be equal that's
what happens when you multiply through
by cos
three times successively so how do i
reason that what i would say is
but
i'm going to say that cos t
is going to be between naught and 1 for
this particular domain right from t
to pi on 2 right
therefore
the area under a curve
will be
lower
on
successive multiples of
or successive multiplications of cos t
because you're multiplying by something
that can either be the same size or
smaller right so i'm going to say of cos
t right so therefore what that tells me
is that this over here i can duplicate
that
that is going to be
less than or equal to the same thing but
you know before you multiply it by cos t
three times so that's all of this
and i'm just not going to have the plus
three right there okay so this here is
what i've just reasoned through and
obviously it's critical that you
actually say you provide some rationale
some substantiation for your claim and
what you've got here is on the right
hand side look at this this is a n like
i was pointing out before so i can just
kind of make that substitution right i
can say i e
all of this
is unchanged but what you're
substituting on that right hand side is
a
n okay
and so that was it like the previous one
took so much more work but here all i
have to do is to attach this middle term
to the one on the outside and then i can
have three terms one small bigger the
other bigger than the other okay so i'm
going to say that linking
oops
linking with inequality i'm pretty sure
i called it inequality two
let's just go back up there and check
two
ah there it is right there so in fact
i'm just going to grab that right there
there is the left hand part of it
right and if you just follow the logic
from this previous line that is
subsequently less than or equal to that
and that's it that is the result that we
were required to prove
okay fantastic all right